hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the meno during the discussion
between
socrates and this foreigner mino who
claims to be able to talk all about
virtue and tell
socrates what virtue in fact is
there comes a point in the dialogue a
very important
turning point where meno winds up in
perplexity they've tried to define
virtue several times socrates has
pointed out some objections with mino's
attempted
definitions of virtue and mino now finds
himself
at a loss and he says socrates this is
why
people say that you are like
a stingray you're like
an animal which stuns it's
it's prey or stuns the the things that
it comes into contact
with and i am similarly
at a loss as if i'd been hit by that
sort of thing
you know we often say something hit me
like a ton of bricks
it's the same sort of idea that you know
for a moment at least we are
unable to come to terms with whatever is
going on we're
we're at a loss we can't make sense of
it we thought that we knew what was
going on
and now we find that we're not able to
to give a
coherent account that we thought we were
able to do before so what we become
aware of
is an inability and we feel it as a loss
because we think that we had some sort
of capacity
and then somebody else took it away from
us here's where it gets particularly
interesting
this analogy or this likening as
socrates calls it
has socrates being like a person who
stings
other people who have knowledge and he
thereby takes it away from them
and socrates says no what i actually
communicate to you
and is my own perplexity i don't know
myself and so i'm able to get across to
you
the fact that i don't know and the fact
that you
trying to inform me with what you claim
to know didn't really work and you don't
know either
so it's a way of socrates communicating
a state of
necessity a state of awareness of one's
own
lack of knowledge one's own ability
to produce some sort of coherent
systematic
covers it all account of whatever the
phenomenon is
and so socrates says look i i myself
don't have
knowledge um this is revealing to you
your own lack of knowledge
and the question now that we have to ask
is
is this a bad thing or a good thing and
that really depends
on your perspective and your point of
view
if you view being able to talk
whether you actually know what you're
talking about or not about some
phenomenon
as the good thing and somebody else
comes along and shows you up and says
well you really you
you can't answer questions you can't
coherently argue for whatever it is that
you're advancing
you really don't know what you're
talking about somebody comes along and
does that
then you feel that they've taken
something away from you it's a bad thing
but if you're actually ignorant here's
another way to look at it this is the
way that socrates looks at it and the
way that mino i think looks at it
if you are actually ignorant then
isn't it advance to find out that you
are indeed ignorant if you are
resourceless
resourceless isn't it an advance
to find out that you are lacking the
resources that you thought that you have
you can only go out and acquire
knowledge if you don't already think
that you know it
you can only go out and get the
resources that you need
if indeed you realize that you don't
have them if you think that you have
them already you'll never go to get them
you know we could put this in terms of
other things you won't start
exercising and getting your body
stronger
until you realize that you you actually
have a need for it if you feel that
you're already strong enough well then
you don't need to do anything additional
and then when it comes time to actually
use your body
or use your resources or use your
knowledge
you find out that you you can't actually
do it that you don't measure up that
what you thought you had
you're actually missing so socrates is
actually doing a very good
thing for me now and and all the other
interlocutors by
extension who he is communicating with
who is showing look you you say
this but you actually are wrong about
that you
you say that you know that x is is y
but it turns out that x isn't y you
say that you have some sort of capacity
or skill but
when you're actually put to the test you
don't you don't have that now you can go
out and actually
do that so you could think of this as
sort of a
you know a harsh medicine rather than
just you know an attack
a harsh medicine that takes away from
the person
something that they thought that they
had but actually just reveals
that they never had it in the first
place in this case
it has to do with knowledge but we could
think of this in terms of
of other things as well and whether one
person is better off
knowing that they're in that case one
last thing i do want to point out
oftentimes uh people will say well if
you yourself don't measure up to this
standard you can't hold
other people to this this standard and
so
you know in moral terms people will
often say look if if you're not a moral
person yourself you don't get to
criticize other people's morality
or their choices or their their bad
habits or anything like that
and is that something that could be
objected to
this socrates
is willing to admit that he himself does
not
know that he himself is perplexed
that's what he says he communicates to
the
other person he gets it across to them
that not only is socrates perplexed and
socrates is a pretty smart guy
but that person is also perplexed they
don't know what what they're actually
what they think they know what they're
talking about what they perhaps are an
expert in
does socrates have to possess some sort
of
knowledge in order to be able to do this
the answer is no we can in fact realize
our
own lack of knowledge our own ignorance
about things
provided that we don't suffer from other
intellectual difficulties like
stubbornness
or foolishness or obstinacy or
things along those lines pride so
socrates is is actually
doing something here that he like i said
he's going to do it many other dialogues
this is part of the socratic method this
is a
really key point in the dialogue where
meno
is getting it it's painful for him to
get it
it feels bad not just in a sense of
perhaps getting a headache
or embarrassment but it really
bothers him that he thought that he knew
what he was talking about and turns out
that he's not able to
to make sense of it with another person
this is
a key part of socratic
inquiry and it prepares us for being
able to carry on
further inquiry we clear away the ground
of what we
thought we knew but don't actually know
so that we can now
build up something that we actually can
say we know